americans may may be facing more
economic hardships in addition to rising
gas prices and inflation president biden
now warning the country to get ready for
an incoming food shortage because of the
war in ukraine
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
talked about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
according to a fox news poll voters are
getting fed up and blaming the president
and his policies for making the economy
worse with 53 percent seen saying that
he is at fault
katie
yes ma'am
i'm old enough to remember when everyone
was complaining that biden wasn't
shooting straight about these issues and
it was obfuscating and and now he's
telling the truth shouldn't this
actually be applauded i mean it's it's
him telling the truth should be
applauded but the fact that we are in
america in the year 2020 with a food
shortage should not be applauded as a
result of his policies so i'm old enough
to remember that last summer jenn
stockey stood at the white house podium
and laughed and mocked the idea that
americans were having their treadmills
delayed two lakes when there was a
supply chain crisis and i said on this
show wait until people can't get food to
their homes and you're going to have a
way more serious problem now now here we
are and it's proving that americans and
people all over the world in their own
countries have to start thinking about
producing their own country sustaining
products whether it's fertilizer that
we're now saying there's a shortage of
so food can't be grown
food that we import from the rest of the
world energy antibiotics medicine
personal protective gear that we saw
china take a monopoly of during the
pandemic so it erases that this idea
that we can always rely on other
countries to make sure that we can
sustain ourselves here at home and
president biden says it's going to be a
real thing without offering a solution
and saying but don't worry i have a plan
to combat this coming food shortage and
this is what my administration is going
to do he throws it out there is this
like a bomb like get ready america
without some kind of plan to try and you
know mitigate the disaster that he says
is coming
so russia supplies i think it's 40 of
the world's wheat
what kind of plan could he throw out
there this quickly i'm not saying that
we don't have to become more independent
as it were but what is a viable solution
to this because this isn't just us
i don't know i don't know
celiac disease for us yes why do we why
do democrats win elections when this
always happens it's like they can't
handle we know they can't handle foreign
policy we know they suck at the economy
the only thing they can do is raise our
taxes that spend that money on programs
that then expand the problem i'm old
enough to remember jimmy carter and i
miss him um this is a consequence of the
laptop cover-up jessica do you like
ashton kutcher
did you enjoy that recently
the butterfly effect remember that movie
i do remember let's do the butterfly
effect here using the laptop number one
what the new york post publishes the
laptop story and then tech and media and
the democrats collude together to bury
it and and therefore we don't know about
the big guy i.e joe biden that
corruption right so that that that is
the cabal that as stated in uh time
magazine so instead of losing the
election which he would have if that was
public he wins the election thanks to
the cabal and then the unpredictable
force of trump is missing and then we
have obama part three cook the cocoon
edition
and then putin sees that opening
uses the u.s ukraine agreement renato on
november 10th to invade
famine that's the butterfly effect it
goes all the way back to the laptop
cover-up you can publish that
and make it into a movie
it's friday are you going to that movie
well the book was better than the movie
and i never say that yeah
you agree i know i do agree they do um i
so i have a wheat guide you want to hear
what my wheat guy says yeah i have a
weak guy my weak guy says that the last
time this happened in 2010 wheat prices
doubled and you had the arab spring and
five governments got knocked off and you
had the syrian civil war now they're
saying it's going to be six times as big
of a price chump so he sees civil unrest
in the mideast sub-saharan africa
southeast asia and brazil because of
this because you also got the fertilizer
scarcity and
america is not going to be that bad
because we have a lot of wheat producers
and we ask we export a lot of money a
lot of wheat so we're gonna have to bail
out the farmers he predicts throw a lot
of money cut a check to the farmers um
and he says every
uh time wheat prices double it adds a
quarter to a loaf of bread so
start saving because things are about to
get very expensive my weak guy is also
my geopolitical guy and he says you're
going to have a food shortage an energy
crisis and a global
recession all in the next two years
should we get fat right now let's let's
be like squirrels and just put it on so
we can get through yeah
your weak guy says what i don't have a
weak guy you know what because i'm
thinking of going gluten-free anyway but
i think you're right greg
the look the crazy part of all this is
that worst sanctioning or we think we're
sanctioning putin right to deter
uh from from fighting the war in ukraine
except
we're not really sanctioning him because
it doesn't really it doesn't seem like
it's doing any good but now we've got a
real issue and that is that there's
going to be world hunger i mean that's
what it looks like and i don't mean to
you know to be a
you know with someone bringing gloom and
doom but you would think that you know
we wouldn't that we would try to protect
whether it's a wheat field or fertilizer
or whatever needs to be protected
recognizing that that is that can create
world chaos and it can create as you
said you know governments being
overthrown leaders being overthrown i
mean we're in for a bit of a mess
because this one guy putin this
genocidal maniac decided that he wanted
to go into a country and just level it
and kill everybody i mean
it to me it's so obvious i mean the
russian people now can't in any way be
in favor of him if the russian people
are are now starting to say that they're
killing their own generals in ukraine
then you know he's got to go
it's the only thing he's got to go
so do we right
we absolutely do hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else